the grand dolby theater has been home to
the academy awards since 2002
and we'll be back here again next year
but the times have called for a pause
while we
grapple with all the changes around us
times are always changing of course
but it's fascinating how often they
repeat themselves
let me set this scene it's a raging
tail end of a pandemic many
millions of lives are lost many millions
more
permanently dislocated and changed
forever
people wonder how will we move forward
the year is 1921 after the worst
pandemic in history
actors mary pickford and gene herschel
took action
raising money for the motion picture and
television fund
a foundation that would provide a
remarkable range
of health services and aid to anyone who
worked in the film or television
industry
one hundred years later we find
ourselves in another global pandemic
this time the mptf knew how to answer
the call
because they had been doing it for
decades
in 1942 the motion picture and
television fund
broke ground on what would become the
lew wasserman campus in woodland hills
from actors to makeup artists from
electricians to carpenters
from painters to teamsters the motion
picture and television fun was created
to help those who
for whatever reason fell on hard times
the film lab chemist who developed
alzheimer's found a home at the mptf
a gay hair and makeup artist whose death
left his life partner unable to receive
his pension
because their 40-year union was not
recognized as a marriage
the mptf was there to help being a
single mother in this industry
is hard but having my son lose his
father
made it a lot harder but naomi and mptf
were there for us
my family and i will always remember the
grace
with which my husband travis died in the
motion picture
television fund that allowed him to
define the terms
of how that happened i have a special
connection to the mptf
when my mother peggy a former actress
was diagnosed with alzheimer's the mptf
offered her a caring and loving home for
her final years
as well as her last sweet romance today
over 250 residents call the wasserman
campus their home
their ages ranging from over 60 to
nearly 100
these glorious people hold the history
of film and television in their stories
and experiences
keeping these residents safe during
covid seeing to their health needs
keeping them socially distant and
socially connected
was an overwhelming challenge but the
mptf staff and volunteers
never left their side often sacrificing
time with their own families to take
care of the residents
quite simply they are our heroes working
beyond the call of duty
it's the 100th anniversary of the mptf
and we have with us 70 of those
vaccinated healthcare and social workers
whose compassion compelled them to step
up and take action to help those in need
it is with infinite gratitude and great
pride that we honor them all tonight
on behalf of the motion picture and
television fund ceo bob beecher is here
to accept this year's
gene herschel humanitarian award
brian thank you for those kind words
they mean
so much to us coming from a member of
our mptf family
jennifer norma and i want to express our
gratitude to david rubin
dawn hudson and the academy board of
governors
for recognizing the motion picture and
television fund tonight
with this very special honor especially
since this is the first time the award
has gone to an organization
thank you to our boards who have guided
us and supported us over the years
your kind words during the pandemic were
cherished
much appreciation to the thousands of
small and large donors
who sustain our charity and to our
volunteers
whose contribution of their personal
time is so
essential to our mission here's to the
tens of thousands of freelance workers
in our entertainment community
those in front of and behind the camera
they are the heartbeat of our industry
and for a hundred years
mptf has been their safety net of
support
this year alone mptf connected with our
industry workforce
over 40 000 times
thank you to the residents of the iconic
motion picture home they've had a very
rough 12 months
of social isolation tonight though
they are all together but socially
distant
and watching the oscars to norma
carranza
nurse and to jennifer george social
worker
both of whom exemplify the best in their
fields
and to the rest of our mptf work family
on the front line during the pandemic
the social workers and nurses
doctors and housekeepers activity staff
and food servers
accountants fundraisers i.t techs
producers hr professionals chaplains
cooks and landscapers
they are our industry's superheroes of
2020.
this award is for them and that tens of
thousands of others
who have worked at mptf over the past
100 years
it's the honor of a lifetime for all of
us
to work together and to receive this
award
we really and truly take care of our
and own gene herschel humanitarian
and our president at mptf for 18 years
we're bringing you home tonight
you